what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with ultimatum uh
we get to what I think it's probably one
of the best parts of the story which is
near the end here's the thing this this
is what I say a lot of people say
ultimatum went off the rails but I don't
really think it did like I consider this
to be kind of a part where things just
sort of popped off and went crazy ah but
again like we're basically dealing with
Magneto kind of laying waste to earth in
the Ultimate Universe and it's cool for
what it is
and it's interesting to see it all
happen but this deals with largely like
the Avengers and the various superhero
teams trying to face off against Magneto
now what this does is it basically picks
up really with like dr. Strange's
sanctum sanctorum and the reason why is
because with Captain America basically
rallying the various superheroes of the
Marvel community in the Ultimate
Universe what this means is that
everyone whether they're an enemy
whether they're kind of an outsider cast
off whatever the case may be they've all
basically been rallied under Captain
America in order to lead the charge
against magneto now keep in mind this is
basically the leftovers it's basically
anybody who's managed to survive the
whole experience and so with the
Incredible Hulk country I guess
alongside Spider Man where they're
picking up and him just kind of tearing
up dr. Strange's home a lot of is
because the Incredible Hulk doesn't
really understand what's going on and
much like a child The Incredible Hulk
just destroys what he doesn't understand
what's going on so I'm just going to
start smashing things like this that's
the incredible Hulk's line of logic the
problem with this is that what the Hulk
is done is he's basically unlocked the
forbidden room by literally tearing
through the place he's ripped open the
forbidden room and in doing so he's let
loose of power and so in response to
this spider-man basically dies like he's
he's totally killed in this this entire
situation think kitty pryde is kind of
left to pick up the pieces and so in a
response to this what we end up finding
out is the forbidden room had basically
gained access to Dormammu now this is
something that I want you guys to keep
in mind when it comes to Marvel Comics a
lot of people find this a little bit
confusing because people think about
like the Marvel multiverse and they
think about the Dark Dimension and
Asgard things like that every universe
has its own Dark Dimension meaning its
own place where Dormammu resides every
universe has its own version of Asgard
the alternate universe established that
the funny thing about this is that
Doctor Strange immediately responds and
tries to take out Dormammu and this is
one of the big differences here the
general gist of this is that Dormammu is
power is so extreme that by and large
it's usually believed if he entered into
the main Marvel Universe and like the
Infinity stones or
McKee was not a symbol in time to defeat
him then door mama would probably
destroy everything in existence like he
would he would probably wipe out the
entirety of the universe the difference
here is that in the ultimate universe
doctors I'm sorry Dormammu is still
exceedingly strong but Doctor Strange is
nowhere near as strong as he is in the
main Marvel Universe now again this also
brings in the nature of Doctor Strange
so in the Ultimate Universe Stephen
strange did not like run into the
ancient one and gain his powers by you
know study and meditation thing either
it wasn't the case instead what had
happened was you had the original
Stephen strange Doctor Strange senior
basically who had a son alongside Clea
this you know basically his protege more
or less but the problem was that the the
original Doctor Strange just danced he
was gone one day and nobody ever knew
what happened to him and so CLE arranged
I guess she raised Doctor Strange jr. by
himself but didn't teach him about magic
but as time went on he basically
encountered Wong who took Stephen under
his wing taught him everything about
magic and that leads to what's going on
right here the problem with this is that
because this version of Stephen strange
is so weak where he does try to defeat
Dormammu
it is no challenge whatsoever - I'm
almost just kind of like what is this
and it just snaps him out like that's
literally it
this fight is like five seconds long
it's Stephen strange he launches an
attack it does nothing against or mana
Dormammu ensnares him and what looks
like the crimson bands of cyttorak and
then literally pops his head off and
Doctor Strange dies like that's it it
happens so fast and that's the crazy
thing because people are not used to
that like people are not used to Doctor
Strange is getting rekt so easily
now of course Susan storm has since
recovered from her injuries and then you
also have the the thing Ben Grimm who's
there alongside him but one of the
things that also happened to you as a
door model who had actually captured
Johnny Storm and in doing so he's
basically been harnessing the flames of
Johnny Storm and using it for his own
ends but it gets kind of crazy here
because from this point what you end up
doing is you basically switch over to
the events of the Incredible Hulk now
again the Incredible Hulk kind of
fighting alongside or not really
fighting alongside but essentially
travelling over to where dr. Strange's
and trying to face off against Dormammu
it would be an intriguing situation to
see it happen the problem is that we
don't really see it happen immediately
instead what happens is the military
tries to attack the Incredible Hulk and
Cyclops basically saves them by shooting
down a helicopter and then we switch to
ultimate Hulk versus ultimate Wolverine
now this has happened before and this is
the reason why we really don't get a
repeat of things the way they were
before and the reason for this is
because in the Ultimate Universe
Wolverines adamantium is not nearly as
durable and strong as it
in the main Marvel Universe which is why
when Ultimate Hulk first fought ultimate
Wolverine he was able to successfully
tear him in half because he adamantium
is just not that strong it's not
indestructible and so what we end up
doing is we kind of sidetrack for a
second we jump over to Nick Fury the
original Nick Fury are not really the
original but like Samuel Jackson Nick
Fury who again it basically been
confined to like the squadron supreme
universe now the reason why he's here
I'm sorry the reason why Reed Richards
Doctor Doom and an end cover you're here
is because of the fact that they're
basically looking for Nick Fury's help
now this is designed to feed into the
main Marvel Universe classic Nick Fury
and what I mean by that is if you're
talking about like the old white guy
Nick Fury in the may Marvel Universe the
guy always had a back-up plan
like he always he had bunkers everywhere
and we mean that was like one of the big
things of age of Ultron right like age
of Ultron happens Ultron travels or he
uses the vision in the product in the
present day to basically start spawning
a litany of Ultron robots kills although
almost all the superheroes on earth
Captain America spider-man like a
handful of heroes are left Captain
America is basically given up and then
he remembers Nick Fury's got bunkers and
there's a there's a time platform we can
use is probably there that belong to
Doctor Doom because dr. doom is long
since been destroyed and so they
traveled to the bunker only to find Nick
Fury's there and he's a lot the guy the
guy is is like that's one of the crazy
things like original Nick Fury back in
the day knew the guy was amazing like
like the way he was written was so cool
like he would like when he went
underground that's exactly what it meant
you didn't find him but regards to this
situation here this group basically
showing up and meeting meeting you know
Samuel Jackson Nick Fury it falls in
line with main Marvel Universe's Nick
Fury because Samuel Jackson Fury
essentially just kind of had all these
different protocols in place but knew so
much stuff because he'd been around for
so long and he really kind of had this
idea or something equivalent to like the
Xavier protocols in the sense of I've
got all these different scenarios mapped
out and like how should how should we
respond accordingly so it's really one
of these things worse like a desperate
situation now where they initially ask
him hey like will you come back Nick
Fury says I will but only if dr. doom
tells the truth and that's when we end
up finding out dr. doom was the one that
had a scarlet witch killed basically had
her murdered which was one of the
reasons all this stuff set in most a set
in motion the other half of this was the
death of Quicksilver now of course this
was covered in the pre lewd to ultimatum
in an ultimate power didn't really see a
reason to cover it I guess we could but
the crazy thing about this is that this
version of Doctor Doom is really
intriguing ultimate doctor
is nowhere near as interesting capable
or smart as as main marvel universe dr.
doom and the reason for this is because
the ultimate version is designed to be
more grounded main Marvel Universe
Doctor Doom is kind of like just oh my
god that guy's crazy with magic and he's
super smart and he has all these
different things but that's that's
that's flights of fantasy no one can
ever be on that level ultimate Doctor
Doom was designed to be more grounded
and not really be like that now the fact
that this version of Doctor Doom is not
that smart is actually what makes him
interesting that's what makes him
intriguing the fact that he can't
predict the end of all you know the how
everything will unfold and he's just not
that I mean he's smart but in terms of
like comparing him to like main Marvel
Universe to him it's no contest here but
the revelation that he's essentially the
person that instigated all of this
really kind of sets things off and it
really sends things in a direction where
like everybody blames doom now so of
course Nick Fury ends up travelling back
with him but at this point we switch
over to this to the Citadel of Magneto
and of course Warren Worthington
basically makes his move and that was a
whole idea here Warren Worthington
earlier in the story was like look I'm
so pissed off - magneto did what he did
I'm gonna take him out myself but that's
stupid because Warren Worthington is not
Archangel he's just a guy with wings
he's basically like one of the most
useless members of the x-men ever which
is how he was originally and so when he
shows up here and says I want to defeat
Magneto it's him being reckless and
emotional and not fully thinking things
through and what happens is exactly what
you would think happens he literally
comes flying in goes to attack Magneto
and magneto is like Sabretooth he's all
yours and Sabretooth comes flying in and
just massacres Warren Worthington now
with this version of say what you hear
what you have is something this very
reminiscent of like Chris Claremont
Sabretooth just like hardcore and
unbridled just rage and destruction so
it's it's kind of cool is it it's a
pretty interesting throwback but from
here we pick up with Valkyrie now that
pre showing up on the scene again is to
kind of be the stand-in for Thor is
really what this is but this goes
exactly as you would expect I mean it's
a girl who's wielding a metal sword who
runs up on a guy that can control
magnetism
it's not gonna end well and it doesn't
now that you know initially gets his arm
cut off right I mean that's one of the
things bear in mind Valkyrie is not like
a weak chick right she don't like just a
girl who's there to look pretty you know
and and that's it I mean that's there's
a lot more to of them that like she's a
pretty hardcore and fierce warrior and
this is illustrated by the fact that
where magneto does you know like slicer
throat using the sword it doesn't
actually kill her as it was kind of
crazy but then you have basically like
the rest of the Avengers who show up
Captain America and all those guys and
then magneto just like collapses the
roof
so it's just like Jesus I mean it's it's
awesome to see this happen it's also to
see this unfold and he literally
cauterizes his own wound with his like
with his magnetic powers so I mean
you're talking about a pretty brutal guy
like a pretty brutal set of
circumstances and that's why again I
love this version and I need up so much
because he's just so dark and he's just
so evil and so what he ends up doing
here is basically just like reading you
know showing up to what [ __ ] like like
literally taking off and coming face
front with with the rest of the x-men
and really like Iron Man and a handful
of other heroes and so it's like okay
fine if this is how it ends then this is
how it ends and I'm not you know unlike
the main our universe where you might
roll over or he might retreat to like
another base of operations Magneto's
like you know this fight ends here like
this this is this is literally the last
stamp and so this is essentially like
magneto versus the Marvel Universe but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comics explain make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the Rob core if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]